bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d' une des expériences les plus dingues
de la mécanique quantique une expérience
bizarrement très peu connu du grand
public et qui nous montre un truc
incroyable sur la nature profonde de la
réalité qui nous entoure en mécanique
quantique
il y a une idée centrale mais étrange
celle qui dit que les objets quantique
puisse être dans des états superposés
prenons l'exemple de l'atome d'hydrogène
un seul proton avec un électron dont on
s'imaginerait qui lui tournent autour
un peu comme une planète et bien d'après
la mécanique quantique l'électron ne
serait pas localisée de façon précise
quelque part sur une trajectoire mais il
serait plutôt dans une superposition de
plein de positions possibles
un peu comme s'ils étaient partout à la
fois autour du proton ou plutôt nulle
part en particulier la seule chose que
la mécanique quantique nous décrivent
c'est la probabilité de présence de
l'électron en chacun des points qui
correspond à la probabilité de le
trouver ici ou là si on fait une mesure
pour essayer de le localiser
mais si on ne fait pas de mesure
l'électron reste dans un état superposé
sans localisation bien défini autre
exemple en mécanique quantique certaines
particules possède une propriété qu'on
appelle le spin et qui pour simplifier
peut être vu comme une petite
aimantation orienté soit vers le haut
soit vers le bas soit dans une
superposition des deux mais si on essaye
de mesurer ce spin
on ne verra jamais de superpositions on
trouvera toujours l'une des deux
réponses au hub à mai avec par exemple
50 % de probabilités pour chacune cette
notion de superposition d'états et de
résultats de mesure probabiliste qui
dépendrait du hasard ça paraît assez
difficile à se représenter pour nous ça
n'arrive jamais dans notre quotidien
les objets qui nous entourent sont
toujours quelque part avec une
orientation bien défini ils sont pas à
la fois à l'endroit et à l'envers ou
localiser un peu partout dans l'espace
le physicien erwin schrödinger un des
fondateurs de la mécanique quantique
name est d'ailleurs pas trop cette idée
de superpositions et c'est pour
illustrer son trouble qu'il a imaginé sa
fameuse expérience de pensée du chat je
pense que vous la connaissez
il s'agit de mettre un chat dans une
boîte à côté d'un dispositif
yves destinée à le tuer et qui est
déclenchée par un système quantique dans
un état superposé
si on en croit la mécanique quantique
dans la boîte le chat serait dans un
état superposé donc à la fois mort et
vivant
du moins tant qu'on n'ouvre pas la boîte
puisque c'est le fait de regarder à
l'intérieur qui forcerait en quelque
sorte le chat à se matérialiser soit
dans l'état vraiment vivant soit dans
l'état vraiment mort généralement quand
on rencontre cette idée de superposition
d'états
on a envie de penser comme schrödinger
on se dit que ça n'est pas réellement
possible un chat est mort ou vivant mais
pas les deux à la fois et donc ça doit
être pareil par exemple dans l'atome
d'hydrogène
on a envie de penser que l'électron est
toujours quelque part en particulier par
partout à la fois autour du proton à la
limite ce qu'on peut très bien
l'admettre c'est qu'on ignore son état
exact
si vous avez un chat dans une boîte tant
qu'on n'a pas ouvert la boîte on ne
s'est effectivement pas s'il est mort ou
vivant on peut dire que de notre point
de vue il est statistiquement à la fois
mort et vivant
mais dans ce cas ce serait juste un
effet de notre ignorance
en réalité dans la boîte le chat il
serait véritablement soit l'un soit
l'autre et le fait d'ouvrir la boîte ne
ferait que révéler son véritable état
qu'il a toujours eue c'est un peu comme
quand je tire à pile ou face
tant que je n'ai pas retiré ma main on
peut dire qu'il est à 50% de chances
qu'elle soit sur piles 50% surface on
peut pour faire certains calculs
d'écrire la pièce comme un mélange
statistiques de 50% pile 50% face mais
en réalité sous ma main elle est bien
dans un des deux états et quand je
retire ma main je révèle lequel il n'ya
pas réellement de superposition d'états
de la pièce c'est juste que moi je n'ai
initialement pas toute l'information
intuitivement la mécanique quantique ça
devrait être pareil chaque fois qu'on
parle d'état qui sont des superpositions
chaque fois qu'on utilise des
probabilités de présence eh ben on se
dit que c'est juste une manière de
quantifier notre ignorance des états
exacts
l'électron serait finalement toujours
quelque part et le fait de le mesurer ne
ferait que révéler sa position réelle
non c'est en tout cas ce que freud inger
pensait ssq einstein pensée également
pour lui la réalité doit avoir une
existence objective et cette histoire de
superposition quantique n'était qu'une
description mathématiques incomplète
pour masquer notre ignorance de
l'état réel des choses alors tous ces
débats sur la nature de la réalité
quantique ont commencé dans les années
1920 1930
dès l'époque des premières formulations
de la mécanique quantique mais près d'un
siècle plus tard on y voit un peu plus
clair sur ces questions fondamentales et
on sait que la réalité des choses est
plus tordus que ce que croyait
schrödinger est pas vraiment non plus
comme l'espérait einstein et si on le
sait c'est notamment grâce à un certain
nombre d'expériences extrêmement
troublante comme celle que je vais vous
décrire aujourd'hui
[Musique]
cette expérience a été proposée par le
physicien lucien hardy en 1993 et
réalisé quelques années plus tard en
utilisant un dispositif à base de laser
de filtres polariseur et de détecteurs
de photons mais expliquer avec des
photons ça n'est pas forcément très
immédiat de se rendre compte de son
caractère très perturbant alors je vais
l'expliquer avec des gâteaux
imaginez une cuisine dans une pièce
complètement fermé avec un cuisinier à
l'intérieur qui fait des gâteaux à
l'extérieur deux tapis roulant
proviennent de la cuisine et à
intervalles réguliers
disons toutes les dix secondes de
gâteaux sorte de façon simultanée un sur
chaque tapis alors à priori on n'a pas
de raison de penser que les gâteaux soit
identique 1 simplement ils sortent par
perdre comme ça à l'extrémité de chaque
tapis roulant on a placé un opérateur
chargé de tester les gâteaux et il y a
deux tests possibles
le premier test c'est tout simplement de
manger le gâteau pour voir s'il est bon
ou pas on va supposer que c'est un truc
objectif qui a pas d'ambiguïté chaque
gâteau et soit clairement bon soit
clairement mauvais le second test
possible c'est de mettre le gâteau dans
une machine qui va analyser sa teneur en
magnésium et on va supposer que là aussi
il n'y a que deux réponses possibles
soit le gâteau contient du magnésium
soit il n'en contient pas et notons qu'à
priori on a pas d'hypothèse sur le rôle
possible du magnésium et son impact
éventuel sur le goût du gâteau on n'en
sait rien la seule contrainte du
dispositif c'est que quand un gâteau
arrive chaque opérateur doit choisir
lequel des deux tests il veut faire
soit ils mangent le gâteau et dans ce
cas il ne peut plus l'analyser dans la
machine soit il analyse mais alors il
n'est plus mangeable pour faire ce choix
on va dire qu'à chaque gâteau qui se
présente à lui chaque opérateur tir à
pile ou face pour déterminer quels tests
effectués et ensuite ils enregistrent
leurs résultats bons ou mauvais s'il l'a
mangé magnésium ou pas de magnésium
s'il a analysé dans la machine et à
chaque paire de gâteau on recommence un
seul test possible de chaque côté chaque
opérateur tirent au hasard et ne fera
donc pas forcément le même test que son
homologue après avoir fait ça pendant un
bon moment disons quelques milliers de
paires de gâteau chaque opérateur a pu
remarquer que certains de ces gâteaux
étaient bons d'autres mauvais que
certains contenaient du magnésium et
d'autres pas rien d'extraordinaire mais
ensuite il dit
de se retrouver et de comparer leurs
résultats en regardant les paires de
gâteaux qui sont sortis ensemble de la
cuisine alors pour chaque paire il ya
trois possibilités soit les opérateurs
ont tous les deux manger leur gâteau
soit ils l'ont tous les deux analysés
pour le magnésium soie lin a analysé le
magnésium de son gâteau tandis que
l'autre a mangé le sien alors commençons
par regarder les résultats qu'ils ont
tenue dans ce cas là celui où ils ont
chacun réalisé un test différents ils
comparent leurs notes et là ils
s'aperçoivent d'un truc assez
remarquable si l'opérateur de gauche a
analysé le magnésium et à trouver qui en
avait alors l'opérateur de droite a
toujours trouvé que son gâteau à lui
était bon toujours est pareil quand les
analyses ont été faites dans l'autre
sens si celui de droite a trouvé du
magnésium dans son gâteau celui de
gauche a systématiquement trouvé que le
sien était bon ok alors pourquoi pas on
ne sait pas ce qui se passe dans la
cuisine et comment sont fabriqués ces
gâteaux on pourrait essayer d'émettre
des hypothèses qui expliquerait cette
corrélation mais pas besoin pour
l'instant on va s'en tenir simplement
aux résultats quand l'un des deux
gâteaux contient du magnésium
alors l'autre est bon regardons
maintenant les chiffres quand les
opérateurs ont tous les deux analyse et
le magnésium dans leur gâteau respectifs
et bien là on trouve tous les cas de
figures parfois aucun des deux gâteaux
n'en contenaient parfois un seul des
deux et parfois les deux en contenait le
seul chiffre important pour nous et
celui ci dans 9 % des cas les deux
gâteaux de la paire contenait du
magnésium
ok très bien maintenant regardons le
dernier cas celui où les deux opérateurs
ont mangé leur gâteau
et bien je vous pose la question
suivante à votre avis dans quel
pourcentage des cas auront-ils trouvé
que les deux gâteaux étaient bons
je répète ce qu'on sait un camp les deux
analyses leurs gâteaux dans la machine
dans 9 % des cas ils trouvent tous deux
du magnésium et quand l'un analyse et
l'autre manche
si l'un contient du magnésium alors
systématiquement l'autre gâteaux et
bonbons question donc quand les deux
mange leur gâteau dans quel pourcentage
des cas les deux gâteaux sont ils bons
je vous laisse réfléchir
prenez un peu de temps mais tu es pause
si vous voulez alors certains d'entre
vous auront certainement répondu 9%
bah oui dans 9 % des cas les deux
gâteaux du magnésium
or quand l'un
du magnésium l'autre est forcément bon
et réciproquement donc ça doit faire 9 %
de cas où les deux sombres ça semble
assez logique j'ai quand même voulu
poser la question à quelques amis
d'après mes calculs si je ne me suis pas
planter on peut dire qu'il y à au moins
9 % de chances que les deux gâteaux soit
bon au même moment dans il n'y a que la
réponse est entre 9 % et 100 % ce qui
est un grand intervalle
et oui comme eux il y en a peut-être
parmi vous qui ont regardé les choses de
plus près et conclut que la réponse
était au moins 1 9%
car en plus des cas où les deux noms du
magnésium il peut peut-être y avoir
d'autres cas où les deux gâteaux sont
bons même sens magnésium on n'a pas les
données qui permettraient de donner une
réponse précise mais la seule chose
qu'on peut conclure avec certitude c'est
que c'est au minimum 9% et peut-être
plus et maintenant si je vous dis que
quand nous deux opérateurs coup par
leurs résultats ils se rendent compte
que la réponse est zéro quand tous les
deux ont mangé leur gâteau respectifs
jamais les deux gâteaux n'ont été bon en
même temps jamais surprenants comme
résultat d'expériences non way voire
carrément impossible prenons un de ces
cas où les deux gâteaux et du magnésium
ça arrive dans neuf pour cent des pères
pour lesquelles on a fait l'analyse des
deux côtés les gâteaux arrive au bout du
tapis roulant si on les analyse sous les
2 on sait qu'on trouve qu'ils ont chacun
du magnésium messi à droite l'opérateur
l'avaient mangé à la place il aurait
forcément trouvé qu'il était bon
puisqu'on l'a dit
chaque fois qu'on a du magnésium d'un
côté si de l'autre côté on mange le
gâteau alors il sera bon donc le gâteau
de droite il est forcément bon en plus
de contenir du magnésium mais
symétriquement si celui de gauche
avaient mangé le sien vu que celui de
droite à du magnésium
on aurait aussi trouvé qu'il était bon
donc les deux gâteaux sont tous les deux
bouts en plus de contenir du magnésium
donc cette paire de gâteaux aulas si on
les avait tous les deux changé au lieu
d'analyser le magnésium
on aurait forcément trouvé qu'ils
étaient tous les deux bon alors c'est
pas possible qu'en ayant testé des
milliers de paires de gâteaux et donc
des milliers de fois manger les deux
jamais une seule fois on ne soit tombé
sur un cas où tous les deux été bon ce
sera juste produire dans au moins neuf
pour cent des cas c'est imparable
et pourtant quand on a fait l'expérience
on a trouvé 0 alors où est l'erreur de
logique comment c'est possible
bien quand je fais mon petit
raisonnement qui conduit à conclure
qu'il doit y avoir au moins 9% de pères
qui sont à la fois bonnes et contenant
du magnésium
je fais sans m'en rendre compte une
hypothèse implicite
je suppose que le fait d'être bons ou
mauvais et de contenir ou pas du
magnésium
ce sont des propriétés intrinsèques des
gâteaux qui existent indépendamment du
fait que je les mesures ou pas un gâteau
qui arrive au bout du tapis roulant
intrinsèquement soit il est bon soyez
mauvais soit il ya du magnésium soit il
en a pas peu importe le test qu'on va
lui faire ses propriétés existent elles
sont réelles cette supposition implicite
c'est ce qu'en physique on appelle
parfois le réalisme c'est une hypothèse
très naturelle un repensé à ma pièce
tirer à pile ou face
tant qu'elle est sous ma main je ne
connais pas son orientation mais je pars
du principe qu'elle en possède
réellement une indépendamment du fait
que je retire ma main ou pas pour le
regarder
le réalisme c'est quelque chose de très
ancrée dans notre façon de penser et
c'est ce qui explique notre incrédulité
quand on entend parler pour la première
fois de superposition quantique
einstein disait d'ailleurs est-ce que
vous pensez que la lune cesse d'exister
quand on arrête de la regarder
de même on a envie de penser que le chat
est soit vivant soit mort et que
l'électron est forcément quelque part sa
position existe c'est une propriété
réelle qui lui est intrinsèque
indépendante du fait que je le regarde
ou pas et donc ça c'est ce que j'ai
implicitement supposée dans mon
raisonnement avec les gâteaux que leur
propriété était réelle bien définies
indépendamment du fait qu'on les mesure
où pas sauf que si c'était vrai les
résultats d'expériences que je décris
serait impossible à obtenir
pourtant les a vraiment obtenu alors pas
avec des gâteaux mais avec des photos et
j'y reviendrai et les résultats de cette
expérience tendent donc à prouver que
l'idée que les objets et des propriétés
réelles qui existent indépendamment de
nos observations et bien ça n'est pas si
évident pour des objets quantique
la réalité n'est peut-être pas si réel
qu'on voudrait le penser ou en tout cas
elle est différente car quand on y
réfléchit bien il y a tout de même une
autre possibilité qui permet d'expliquer
ces résultats étonnants
imaginez que les gâteaux possède des
propriétés réelles intrinsèque bien
défini il existerait donc vraiment des
gâteaux qui à la fois contiennent du
manière
l'homme et son don dans 9 % des cas mais
supposons que lorsqu'un des opérateurs
décident de manger son gâteau le gâteau
en question envoie un signal
perturbateurs à l'autre gâteau de
manière à le rendre mauvais je sais pas
avec vibration qui va le secouer et
ruiné sombre si ce genre de phénomène
existait ça permettrait d'expliquer les
résultats l'expérience le fait qu'on
n'ait jamais une paire de gâteaux qu'ils
soient tous les deux bons alors qu'on
trouve parfois des pertes de gâteaux
ayant tous les deux du magnésium
le problème c'est que si on éloigne les
deux gâteaux suffisamment et qu'on fait
les mesures de façon simultanée et bien
ça imposerait que cette hypothétique
perturbations voyage presque
instantanément
ce qui paraît assez bizarre le fait que
les objets ne puisse pas influencer de
façon instantanée à distance c'est
parfois ce qu'on appelle le critère de
localités or toutes les théories
physiques raisonnable que l'on connaît
sont des théories locale qui respecte ce
critère accepter que les résultats
étranges de l'expérience soit dû à une
influence instantané à distance entre
les des gâteaux ça voudrait dire
renoncer à ce principe de localités qui
est un des fondements de la physique
pour bien voir regardons comment on fait
l'expérience en vrai pas avec des
gâteaux dans la véritable expérience on
prend un cristal qui quand il est
stimulé d'une certaine façon et mais des
paires de photons dans des directions
opposées et pour chacun des photons on a
un dispositif de filtres polariseur qui
donne le choix entre mesurer deux choses
différentes soit sa polarisation selon
un certain angle alpha soit sa
polarisation selon un autre angle bêta
on a un détecteur de photons derrière
chaque polariseur et à chaque mesure la
réponse est binaire - ou plus c'est à
dire que soit le photon est absorbée par
le filtre soit ils passent et il est
captée par le détecteur et ça de chaque
côté et bien avec certains réglages
particuliers l'expérience on obtient les
résultats que j'ai présentée avec les
gâteaux
si on mesure de chaque côté les
polarisations selon des angles
différents
alors si c'est plus sur alpha c'est
forcément plus sur bêta si on mesure des
deux côtés selon alpha alors dans 9 %
des cas les deux sont plus par contre
jamais les deux ne sont simultanément
plus quand on mesure les deux selon la
polarisation bêta
c'est exactement la même situation
qu'avec les gâteaux quand on mesure les
deux selon alpha et qu'on obtient plus
plus dans 9 % des cas et bien si on
avait au lieu de ça choisi de les
mesurer selon bêta on aurait dû aussi
logiquement obtenir plus plus mais ça
n'arrive jamais donc soit on renonce à
l'idée que les photons possède des
propriétés réelles avant qu'on les
mesure soit on imagine que l'un des
photons quand il se fait mesurer puisse
envoyer un signal à l'autre qu'il
modifie un signal qui voyagent plus vite
que la lumière donc en conclusion à
cause de ce genre d'expérience on est
obligés soit de renoncer au réalisme ou
fait que les objets et des propriétés
objective qui existent même si on les
mesure pas ce qui serait assez dingue
comme conclusion soit on doit renoncer
au principe de localités et accepter que
des trucs puisse influencer
instantanément à distance ce qui est
presque aussi dingue puisque c'est quand
même un des fondements de la physique en
particulier de la théorie de la
relativité
alors quand je vous raconte ça vous dit
peut-être que renoncer à l'un de ses
principes fondamentaux sur la base d'une
seule expérience c'est quand même un peu
exagéré est ce qu on est sur des
résultats
et bien oui on est assez confiant et ce
pour deux raisons la première c'est
qu'on a déjà fait plusieurs autres
expériences qui montre des résultats du
même type et la deuxième c'est que tous
ces résultats sont en fait des
prédictions de la mécanique quantique
donc on s'attendait un peu à ce que ça
donne ça en fait toutes ces expériences
relève d'un phénomène plus général
découvert par le physicien john bell en
1964 et qu'on appelle la violation des
inégalités de bell
les inégalités de bell ce sont des
inégalités mathématiques qui en principe
limite les résultats possibles d'une
expérience
à partir du moment où on suppose que la
nature obéit au principe de réalisme et
de localités ce qu'on dénomme ensemble
le réalisme locale
si le réalisme local est vrai alors les
inégalités de bell sont toujours
respectés et donc si une expérience à
des résultats qui sont en violation des
inégalités de bell
c'est que ses résultats devraient être
impossible à obtenir dans le cadre du
réalisme locale c'est ce qui se passe
avec l'expérience des gâteaux les
inégalités de bell nous dit
il devrait y avoir forcément au moins 9%
de paire de bons gâteaux et on n'en
trouve aucune
les résultats de l'expérience ne
respectent pas les inégalités de bell et
nous forcent à questionner l'hypothèse
du réalisme locale depuis les débats
entre schrödinger einstein bord etc
dans les années 1920 1930 la mécanique
quantique et les travaux de john bell
nous ont permis d'imaginer et de
réaliser un certain nombre d'expériences
de ce genre celle dont je vous ai parlé
aujourd'hui n'a pas été la première et
n'est vraiment pas la plus connue mais
je les choisis parce qu'elle est il me
semble la plus facile à vulgariser pour
commencer dans ces résultats sont
frappants
mais la plus connue de toutes ces
expériences de violation des inégalités
de bell
c'est celle qui a été réalisé à orsay en
1982 par le physicien français alain
aspect et je ferai bientôt un épisode
dédié à cette expérience et à son
importance historique
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui en
attendant si vous voulez plus de détails
sur ce que je vous ai raconté notamment
pour ceux qui connaissent un peu la
mécanique quantique
je vous renvoie au billet de blog qui
comme toujours accompagne la vidéo
abonnez vous mettez la cloche tout ça et
on se retrouve prochainement pour une
nouvelle vidéo
à bientôt
[Musique]